buongiorno a tutti dunque un computer su
ogni scrivania è un sogno di un
personaggio che tutti noi conosciamo un
nome conosciuto bill gates possiamo
assolutamente dire che questo sogno è
stato realizzato già nel 1999 quando
ognuno di noi a casa aveva un nuovo
elettrodomestico che ci permetteva di
fare cose molto semplici ma molto utili
e assolutamente innovative stampare un
immagine a casa poter navigare
all'interno dei nostri file si trattava
però di un silos informativo di qualcosa
che stava sulla nostra scrivania
disconnesso da solo da lì il mi ricordo
ancora 1999 per mio padre esce una
mattina col computer in braccio e diceva
da far mettere internet
erano i giorni di natale io
arrabbiatissimo perché finalmente potevo
giocare con formula 1 tutto il giorno
invece lui no doveva uscire con con il
computer però alla sera quando è tornato
e attaccato quel cavo dietro computer ho
scoperto un mondo nuovo
ci stavamo connettendo stavamo
promettendo delle macchine tra di loro
in verità stavamo connettendo delle
persone e da lì
l'evoluzione continuato a crescere
ancora oggi stiamo vedendo gli effetti
di questa evoluzione
oggi abbiamo assolutamente realizzato un
nuovo concetto quello che possiamo
definire intelligenza ambientale attorno
a noi tutto è social tutto è fatto per
permettere alle persone di condividere
immagini informazioni tutto quello che
vogliono e tutto attorno a noi e smart
tutto misura i dati di quello che
facciamo di quello che siamo di quello
che consumiamo abbiamo esempio ovunque
abbiamo ognuno di noi in tasca uno
smartphone 20 sensori che ci seguono
qualsiasi cosa facciamo abbiamo
frigoriferi intelligenti che sanno
esattamente quanti litri di latte
consumiamo e volendo alla sera
attraverso i dati dello smartphone ci
permettono di consegnare a casa il latte
che abbiamo bisogno per il giorno dopo
abbiamo lenti intelligenti lenti a
contatto intelligenti che ci permettono
di misurare il livello di glucosio nel
sangue e abbiamo addirittura bagni
agenti e qui non mi sembra il caso di
andare oltre su questo punto ma
immaginiamo quanto di noi è descritto
nei dati quanto questi queste tecnologie
che permettono di misurare ogni singolo
nostro momento costruiscono quanto
raccontano e quanto dicono di noi alle
aziende a cui forniamo questi dati
parallelamente a questo sviluppo
continuo incessante abbiamo visto due
fenomeni il primo è quello degli
attacchi informatici
quanti di noi hanno letto sui giornali
ultimamente di situazioni in cui enormi
moli di dati venivano rubate e condivise
nel web
ashley madison 33 milioni di account
rubati e assolutamente a disposizione di
tutti
abbiamo anche errori umani
la clinica di londra che condivide i
dati di tutti i malati di hiv a londra
situazioni in cui dati che non
dovrebbero essere condivisi vengono
rilasciate nel mare del web a fianco
questo fenomeno ne abbiamo un altro che
è quello della profilazione abbiamo
situazioni in cui questa continua
raccolta di dati permette alle aziende a
cui noi forniamo i dati di sapere sempre
più di noi e di inserire nuovi dati di
noi che vanno costruire un profilo e
un'identità un'immagine e una
rappresentazione di noi nel mondo
digitale sempre più complessa sempre più
completa questo doppio fenomeno ha
portato a come dire considerare
soprattutto la profilazione come
qualcosa di negativo ma io non voglio
demonizzare subito quello che potrebbe
essere molto utile perché per esempio
tutta la pubblicità e il marketing in
rete non potrebbe esistere come lo
conosciamo oggi
se non ci fosse un attività di
profilazione che deve essere però
utilizzare in modo corretto nel modo più
giusto ma in verità questi due fenomeni
hanno portato a corrodere la nostra
fiducia in rete cioè la fiducia che nei
mercati digitali è assolutamente il
primo degli elementi attraverso il quale
si costruisce la competitività
attraverso il quale gli utenti si
spostano da una piattaforma all'altra
come dire la nostra la nostra continua a
proliferare di strumenti digitali e
nostra società che vive grazie a questi
strumenti digitali
all'inizio però rendersi conto del
valore delle identità che vengono
raccolte noi stessi siamo la società e
noi stessi ci rendiamo conto di quanto è
importante tutelare queste nostre
identità in rete
siamo anche in un momento molto
particolare perché iniziamo renderci
conto che le stesse tecnologie che
potrebbero di per sé essere usate contro
di noi possono essere usate anche a
favore nostro modo di tutelare i dati a
favore del controllo di tutte le
attività che avvengono sui nostri dati è
fondamentale anche capire cosa sta
succedendo in questo momento tutti i
nostri dati personali che sono raccolti
vengono affidati alle organizzazioni
quindi abbiamo un momento in cui le
organizzazioni raccolgono le
organizzazioni che possono esser enti
pubblici possono essere aziende
raccolgono i nostri dati i nostri le
nostre informazioni personali
all'interno di silos più o meno sicuri
ma sono presso di loro questo è un
modello assolutamente organizzazione
centrico
ecco qui è possibile un cambiamento in
questo punto ci possiamo rendere conto
di quello che possiamo fare per poter
superare questa questa situazione che
assolutamente è diventata non è non è
assolutamente più sostenibile
immaginiamo che ognuno di noi in base a
recenti studi scarica e utilizza e
sottoscrive con tanti servizi digitali
all'anno tanti che non basterebbe un
anno per leggere l'informativa privacy
questo documento giuridico infinito non
basterebbe un anno di tempo per leggere
tutte le informative dei servizi a cui
ci siamo iscritti
dunque la proposta che oggi è quello di
passare da questo modello organizzazione
centrico a un modello di tipo entità
centrico dove l'entità e la persona
quindi modello utente centrico e questo
è possibile grazie a una serie di
strumenti che iniziano esistere come i
personal data space persona detta spese
sono delle cassaforti digitali
immaginiamoci dei contenitori dei nostri
dati tutti i dati che vengono rilevati
da tutte le i sistemi che utilizziamo
vengono mantenuti presso di noi e siamo
noi a decidere quale organizzazione di
utilizza per quanto tempo perché
finalità questo può essere un
cambiamento che potrebbe andare a
impattare proprio su quella fiducia di
cui parlavamo
esempio molto semplice social network
uno non ci piace più come gestisce i
nostri dati non ci piace più il servizio
semplicemente nessun nuovo cosa possiamo
fare oggi sottoscrivere il secondo
servizio e ricopiare manualmente tutti i
dati nel secondo con un personal d'età
space noi potremmo assolutamente
attraverso un click trasferire i nostri
dati che sono nostri
l'esempio più complesso abbiamo tre
conti in tre banche differenti esce un
nuovo servizio di intermediazione
finanziaria che ci potrebbe fornire
servizi utili a previsioni di mercato
utili a costruire nuove modalità di
investimento
ecco i dati se sono nelle nostre
cassaforti digitali possono essere
facilmente trasferiti a questo nuovo
player di mercato questo nuovo attore
dunque questo è un servizio è uno
strumento un approccio che è utile prima
di tutto agli utenti gli utenti possono
finalmente avere a propria disposizione
immaginiamo un sito una dashboard dove
vedono in tempo reale chi sta facendo
che cosa con i propri dati possono
esercitare i loro diritti possono
cancellare quei dati possono riprendere
il controllo dei dati ritirare il
consenso e possono anche segnalare che
quell azienda non sta facendo quello che
aveva promesso di fare infatti secondo
fattore che ha assolutamente un
vantaggio da questo tipo di strumento
sono le imprese le imprese possono
basare tutto il loro mercato tutto il
loro modo di gestire i clienti e sulla
fiducia devono dimostrare devono essere
si dice in inglese account devono
permettere alle persone di entrare nel
nel sistema e vedere cosa sta succedendo
se no io utente ritiro il servizio e mi
riferisco all altra azienda che offre un
servizio simile ma più utile ma più a
tutela della mia privacy e infine le
pubblica amministrazione un grande
problema delle pubbliche amministrazioni
non avere dati di qualità e continui
flussi di dati attraverso il quale
misurare e programmare le politiche
pubbliche ecco con questi sistemi
ma non iniziando ovviamente questi dati
né possiamo avere una visione complessa
che permette di andare a programmare
tutti gli interventi futuri
riassumendo siamo passati da un computer
fisso e statico a un intelligenza
ambientale attacchi informatici e
profilazione hanno rischiato di
corrodere profondamente la nostra
fiducia on line la privacy 3.0 di cui
abbiamo parlato oggi è il modello
gestito e reso possibile dai personal
data space dove utenti imprese pubbliche
amministrazioni diventano più
competitivi in un mercato digitale unico
europeo
grazie mille